تذكر أنني أخبرتك أنني سأفعل تلك
الحديقة العضوية
وهذا ما أفعله أنت تعلم أن
كاميرتك على اليمين يمكنني رؤيتك
تعلق هنا وسأعود فورًا
لا لا لا توجد مشكلة لا بأس ،
هذا على الأرجح  يبدو أفضل بالنسبة لك ،
حسنًا
[موسيقى]
ماذا عن تناول شاي بعد الظهر مع الدجاج الخاص بك ،
لا أرى حقًا ، لا أعتقد حقًا
أن
الشاي مع الدجاج
حصلنا أخيرًا على وشم مطابق ،
أعني جيدًا أنك تعلم أن لدي بالفعل
شيئًا مشابهًا حقًا على ظهري
هذا الشخص  أنت وهذا الشخص
أنا لأنني أحيانًا مثل ، هل نحن توأم
كما تعلمون ربما نقوم بتوفيره عندما أبلغ
سن الخمسين.
[موسيقى]
أكثر من 2 مليون امرأة في الولايات المتحدة وحدها
وعشرات الملايين حول العالم
قد فقدوا وظائفهم بسبب
covid وأعتقد أننا جميعًا نفعل ذلك ونلتزم جميعًا بـ
40 دقيقة لنوع من
الخدمة النشطة يمكننا إنشاء تأثير مضاعف
لك